there could be an iframe on their page there could be an iframe on your page you could be
iframeing your own page iframeing your own page to create a null origin which is a separate origin
from your attacker page and then use that null origin to open up another page
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing all right hackers i was just
looking into this and i think i figured out how threat locker elevation control works okay so when
a user launches an elevated processor they try to threat locker agent will hook that into its own
elevation flow so we don't see any uac prompt or anything the threat locker admin will be able
to grant that process elevated permissions for a certain amount of time or whatever very granular
control there and then the threat locker agent on the user's device injects a modified process
security token which will elevate that process directly this is awesome because it avoids things
like uac which um leaves ntlm hashes and stuff like that in memory right in lsas.axe it creates a time
bounded elevation right and it does the elevation to the process rather than to the user really great
stuff but of course there's always like maintenance mode and that sort of thing if you have to get in
there and do a bunch of administrative activities great stuff by threat locker once again all right
let's go back to the show all right my guy this is the episode of client-side advanced topics i freaking
love this man i freaking this is your uh this is your dream yes um all right so we got a lot of stuff on
the docket today about client-side advanced topics essentially the the vision for this episode was just me
kind of brain dumping all of the things that i think are a little bit above um you know intermediate
tier uh as far as client-side hacking goes so i'm going to kind of lay out all those things that i think are really cool
and you are going to play the listener and try to repeat these back to me and try to ingest this information
and make sure i'm not like going too fast or too over the top with the explanation yeah yeah it's really
easy to make mental leaps whenever you're the you know quote-unquote expert on it right so exactly
perfect quote-unquote expert on it what is that supposed to mean okay this is actually this is actually a
really good point i never know how much flattery someone can take right i think you're a super expert
whenever i talk to anybody and someone asks me like you know who do i think the most talented hacker
is like you're almost always the first name out of my mouth and so but then i never know people
want to hear that to their face like i feel like usually you'd be like nah or whatever right so
anyways it makes me feel awkward i do that you know if you if you're if you're playing it up then i play it down
and if you're playing it down that's right what are you talking about you know so there's always
some back and forth i guess i like it um appreciate you though joseph um before we hop into that
we actually have a couple news pieces that i did want to show that are relevant to uh this topic
the first one is there's this guy on twitter that's been tweeting out some interesting stuff
lately and it's like um yeah i think there are some people commenting on it be like yeah this is like
well known you know but you know it is what it is uh i i thought that this was very interesting
material so i'll go ahead and share it with you guys um the guy is noaskijr um on twitter and he
shared that uh if you create a uh xss payload that looks like this which i'm putting on the screen but
for audio listeners it is a less than bracket with a question mark and then less than bracket a
and then an href that contains an svg onload in it then that will actually fire and the reason for that
is because um these you know if you do not have an actual um spec compliant uh tag so you know a less
than sign plus an a through z uh character then it's going to encode those and not treat anything
else as a uh actual uh attribute which means they won't be url encoded which means the things inside
of the href there will become the actual html and everything else surrounding it is just text
uh that gets encoded so um this these are kind of interesting uh payloads yeah uh there's another one as
well which is less than zero that's the one that's not a valid tag yeah um they need to start with an ascii
letter um and and if they don't they're not going to be treated like a tag and the encoding is not
going to be applied to the attributes or anything like that um a couple of the comments in here were
saying hey this is pretty much only going to trick like syntax checkers and like you know uh syntax
highlighters and stuff like that but i think it might also be relevant in some waft bypasses as
well they try to do contextually aware um encoding or blocking it makes me think about like what i'm
sure someone's on this before but basically all of the possible um what's the opposite of compliant
spec non-compliant yeah yeah spec non-compliant characters like um that could occur in the first
character and the tags like that and i'm sure that someone has fuss for that or whatever but oh yeah
shazer i'm sure has has a list for that or something like that yeah um so anyway i just thought this
was a really interesting piece here uh i think this is the kind of stuff that makes waft bypasses
um pretty pretty doable and we talked about this a lot in the ryan barnett episode but like
why laughs are fighting a losing battle because they just don't know what's going to be happening
if they're trying to do any contextual aware um stuff so i do think it's kind of an interesting
discussion on like the novelty required for stuff to be shared on social media because i think that like
there's a lot of people who kind of hate on anyone that shares like more beginner information like this
is known but that's clearly a spectrum right and so it's like where on that spectrum should you like not
post stuff or where on the spectrum is like because it's still useful for beginners still like this is
still like news to me maybe a lot of people know it but it was news to me when i saw this tweet i
thought it was neat right but um yeah just kind of interesting kind of meta topic on you know what
you should be sharing because there definitely are some um x accounts and some other social media
accounts that share like such basic information that half of it's wrong and they've kind of just feels
like more like snake oil or engagement farming whereas i don't think this is that at all
no this is this is this guy sharing cool cool stuff that he you know either stumbled upon or learned and
just wanted to disseminate the information i think you were the one that told me this a while back but
like it's something like only 20 or 30 percent of your followers will see on average will see like
your actual post just despite how many views it gets you know there's going to be a larger percentage
that are not going to be you know followers or whatever um so if you really want to disseminate
information to your followers you kind of need to post it like two or three times yeah uh which is
also interesting because it's like okay well even if it even if somebody else posted it you know they've
got a different audience base you know and it does make sense to repost these things and reshare these
cool tips and i mean to be honest that's what we're going to be doing all day on this episode is like
all the stuff that i'm going to talk about here very little of it is actually like just in research
there's like right maybe one or two areas but it's super useful to have it rehashed and it's super
useful to have it explained and it's super useful to have it in one place formalized and and organized
yeah i agree so good stuff here by nawaski thanks for sharing that um the other one is this is an
interesting one i don't know if you saw this dude but there's this guy um boar abdelhadi who is
creating uh something called rep plus which is a lightweight http repeater inside of chrome dev tools
and i just think this is a really interesting place for this to live uh because uh you know a lot of
us are in dev tools anyway have our dev tools open while we're hacking and yeah makes sense that you
might want to replay requests in there especially if you are like you know trying to do some lightweight
hacking or something like that so um really cool project i think it is a little bit handicapped
because i think it is not uh http one compliant i think it uses fetch and it forces everything to be sent over
like http two um but very cool project nonetheless yeah i think in an ideal world if you had to modify
requests you would want to modify it without going through a proxy a proxy is almost like an extra step
right and so i don't think we'll ever get away from using proxy proxies for a long time but i think in
like an ideal world you could just like hack the request in the browser itself that you're using
yeah yeah totally that that is interesting well this is one of the things that is also nice about
kratos like uh client server architecture is like we could probably iframe kaido into dev tools actually
i think i saw somebody do that all right that's funny and cool um so if you really wanted to keep
everything in one spot you could actually put kaido in dev tools um interesting interesting thought
yeah um all right so that's all i had on the news you didn't have any any news items this week that
cropped up did you no i did not have you played with opus 4.5 dude it's really good like not only
do i think it's good but i've seen multiple people okay so let's actually clarify this because gemini
3 is also incredible um i guess one big takeaway is they're both better than 5.1 in my opinion but like
a pretty large margin but um i think opus 4.5 has like a very particular strength when it comes to
debugging and coding i mean gemini 3 is obviously incredible at those as well but i think that opus
4.5 is kind of like a really new state-of-the-art when it comes to front-end frameworks when it comes
to debugging any kind of issue um like it you know i feel like models sometimes would break down when they
were like trying to debug an issue or they would like get a recurring loop like i've seen a lot of people
comment on 4.5 breaking out of that finally where it like doesn't get in these like intense failure
loops and it can often like solve its own problems so yeah that's pretty sick man that that is a big
jump forward and i know that the clod models in particular are pretty sick with uh um like tool
calls and stuff like that which is super important as well so yeah i'm excited to see if you use it
much or if it comes in handy with your project for your nahamsec talk so yeah the naham whoa the nahamcon
uh talk that i'm doing that i'll i'll also drop on the pod um later this month uh we'll be doing some
you know a b testing with different models and stuff like that but so far man it's claude nice it is you
you know the the gemini models as much as i love them and i use them primarily you know outside of this
specific project um which is essentially agentification of our hacking workflows um it's it's not it's not
doing as well with tool calls yeah the tool calls just they'll seem like a larger percentage of the time
right yeah it's a little odd kind of a bummer i i i'm i i am rooting for gemini though i think i think
gemini if they can fix that i think that they're going to be the the best but yeah i'm very bullish on
google in general yeah i think they have the customers the distribution and their models are incredible
um i mean actually we should talk about this for just a split second nano banana banana pro is the
wildest image editing piece of software it's basically um photoshop in a single tool call like it's crazy
ridiculously good i mean it can create advanced slides with lots of text and advanced diagrams like
it would not surprise me if it can yeah i mean i've seen some that are like that are extremely good
but like um it would not surprise me if it could one shot some like flow diagrams for like hacking like
oh off flow diagrams so you should you should test it for that it's really good yeah but when you use
it on 4k res it's also 25 cents per image so be careful that gets expensive fast i mean yeah you
could just use the 1k resolution and then it's like yeah four cents or whatever but wow not four cents yeah
that's that's pretty doable um all right dude let's get into let's get into the meat of it i've got a
lot of fun topics i want to go through today and i'm actually they're kind of not that related so i'll
kind of let you take your pick okay we've got post messages uh third-party cookies cspt's iframe tricks
url parsing and client-side routes any of those stand out to you as like the one we want to hear about
first yeah let's hear about third-party cookies all right third-party cookies is actually uh this is
actually probably the shortest section so um this should be pretty quick in the beginning um i wanted
to talk a little bit on this episode about chips um which is uh essentially how cookies are partitioned
uh when the partitioned value is uh or attribute is attached to a cookie in chrome um because this is a
something that i think we're going to see gain more adoption than it currently has even and um
uh it is helpful for sort of uh threading the needle in some of these cookie situations that you're
dealing with um the the main thing that you need to understand about this is that with chips um cookies
are no longer scoped just to the to the um domain that they're on but they've also got a key for them
uh that is tied to the top level page if that scheme plus eltd plus one so whatever the tld is and then
the the domain um and then inside of that right if there's an iframe or something like that it's tied to the
host so let's say you've got um reinerader.example.com iframe framing in you know um example.rezo.com right
uh so so you used a different cld there i did i did but that's that they need to be different they
need to be different so let's so let's do okay let's let's keep it simple let's do reinerader.example.com
and as iframing rezo.example2.com okay the the the key for that is is going to be um so first the etld
plus one which is example.com right cut off the reinerader piece so there's that and then there's
going to be the whole uh second host which is rezo.example2.com right that smush together is going
to be your your your context for that specific cookie so uh if you have a different you know key
there then it's not going to be able to access that that cookie in a different environment
um however you know if there's you know grep me or whatever.example.com and it iframes in rezo.example2.com
because the tld is the same example.com yes and you know rezo.example2.com that key is going to
collide right and they will be able to share cookies but otherwise you're not going to be able to have
access to cookies inside of an iframe um if the partitioned this is if the partitioned value is set on that
specific cookie um so so the way so right now most sites don't have that you're saying yeah that's
right um but just just you know that's a new cookie value or attribute that has been attached
so something that i wanted to make people aware of to be on the lookout for that and is the primary
mechanism for implementing that the fact that they want iframes to be more secure yeah yeah and it's
also related to some privacy pieces as well okay um so anyway that was all i had on that that one
doesn't have a ton of like exploitation pieces it's just something important to understand is that
that how that key is generated etld plus one our scheme plus etld plus one and then the actual iframe
toast and will the parent one always be kind of wild card like that or can the parent can the parent
one have a subdomain as well no it's going to be it's going to be etld plus one every time okay plus
scheme um all right i'll pick the next one we'll go into post messages next okay post messages are my
shit do you know what all right tell me what you know about post messages joseph do you understand
anything about post messages or should i start from the beginning very little you should start from
the beginning yep okay i'll start i'll start from the beginning so post messages i want you to i want
you to in your explanation explain it in such a way that there's an analogy such that like i can create
a mental picture of it because i think the biggest issue for most people's comprehension of a new
concept is that they don't have a mental picture for it so i think s3 bucket is the best example of this
ever made like the name of the thing is the analogy of the thing right that's cool and and and so like
because of that everyone knows what a bucket is it's like this place you put data right and so i think
like with post messages it's it's never like clicked strongly for me even though i understand that it's
like this site is sending a message to this site but it but it's not um the different ways in which
you can do that are not overly clear because i don't have a good mental picture so if you have a good
good analogy do it and there's also some like overlap too like i remember trying to teach my mentees
about post messages and also post requests you know and those are not the same thing even remotely
right yeah and so um yeah there is some difficulty there post messages i mean do kind of have that
same imagery though if you think about it as like a little like a little post like a little um postcard
that letter like yeah like a little letter i was like the only thing i could come up with japanese
but yeah the little letter um and you're kind of sending it from one tab to the other is it always
via javascript yeah it's always via javascript okay that helps me understand a lot okay yeah it's
always via javascript it's it's a feature of javascript um and the browser you know uh kind of
collaborating together and the concept is you have multiple windows right those windows can be in an
iframe or they can be a tab to be honest it's probably most most easy to think about it being a tab
okay maybe this is one big problem when you say windows everybody knows what you mean from a
front-end perspective yeah if i'm not a front-end guy when you like what do you know windows is it
literally tabs that are open okay so good good differentiation so a window can be a bunch of
different things okay um you you've got a window when you've got a tab open right in your browser it can
be a new window in your browser right so you've got a new actual window right um it can be inside of
an iframe um and those are those are the main ones really uh there are other niche scenarios like okay
technically it's not an iframe it's like a picture in picture you know there's various sdks or whatever
that you can use to do yeah different stuff but um those are the main ones uh and what post message
allows you to do is just do communication between these windows directly rather than via some api cool
yeah that's how i always understood it okay yeah so um you know you use the sdk and it sort of comes
with the browser right so it's you know window.post message you get a window reference you know some
way and then you do window.post message and it just allows you to send a json blob essentially or so the
other window always has a listener um no so the other window has to register a listener so that's one of
the things that's interesting right is is like the other window is going to get it but the code isn't
going to react in any way if you don't register a listener right right yeah um and so yeah that's
that's like a key part of that and then you know the the listeners are kind of what we look at often
and also messages being sent right because sometimes what will happen is you iframe a page
and then it just yeets sensitive data up to the parent right no matter who it is right yeah yeah
because there's some code that just says like parent.post manage or something along the lines
exactly yeah and it just yeets information up so that's sometimes how that works um but other times
uh you know you also got to look closely at the the listeners on the page send it a specific kind
of message then it'll send other data out or do something yeah makes something like that so um anyway
post message not necessarily like an advanced client-side topic i would consider this like a
intermediate or or or lower client-side topic here are some of the things that are more advanced
about post messages that not a lot of people know okay so um one when you register a post message
listener there is an event object that's being passed into the uh the um listener so that event is
what contains the data okay so if you do event.data that's the data that got sent in the post message right
if you do event.source uh it will it will uh give you a reference to the window that sent that that post
message if you do event.origin it will give you the origin of the event that sent the uh origin of the
the window that sent the post message okay okay yep um and what is interesting here is there are such
things as null origins uh in iframe so we're gonna we're gonna sort of pop a little bit over to our our
iframe trick section as well yeah but um essentially uh a lot of times what you'll see in a post message
listeners you'll see okay event.origin needs to uh you know match window.origin which means like this
the same uh origin as sending the event or sending the message is the same one as me right so i'm like
i'm talking with myself pretty much on a different page right um what's really cool though is if you
iframe a uh if you're doing a sandboxed iframe the origin for that uh iframe becomes null and then
here's the really really interesting piece here okay um if you do a uh if you allow that sandbar or
sandboxed iframe to uh control pop-ups to pop open a new window yep you can have it pop open a new
window to any site right you know any arbitrary site and it will inherit the null origin of the page
that opened it weird okay so so now you've opened google.com or whatever right it was an origin
yeah but if a post message pulls the event.origin of that page it will be null still
exactly so and and it's going to compare it to its own window.origin right which will also be null because
it inherited the null origin so now you've just completely bypassed event.origin equals window.origin
that's really cool so if you ever see that there is a way to bypass it basically there is yeah um and it has
some constraints because now you're in a win uh a um null origin iframe you know on this page and a bunch
of stuff might break sometimes the javascript doesn't run quite right and stuff like that um but
it is it is possible to uh invoke that communication uh and and bypass that check if it's using um the
objects window.origin or just origin is that a security feature like is does that get set to null
automatically because whenever you are trying to give sandbox um iframe execution to something it gives you
some sort of security from the parent yeah so the the reason that exists is and i'm going to read it from
the from the docs here because i've actually got it right here um so uh a sandbox resource is otherwise
so unless if you don't specify allow same origin in the sandbox attributes then so just what it is by
default when you're using sandboxed a sandbox resource is otherwise treated as being from an opaque origin
which ensures that it will always fail same origin policy checks yeah so they said it's a null so that
it fails same origin policy yeah and and it's interesting because it's not just null right because
if you if you have two iframes that are both null origin they're gonna say hey we're both in or or
null origin that fails the same origin check and i'm like no that's the same origin but but no it's
not it's a different null right um so those nulls aren't the same but their their string representations
are the same are the same yeah right and so when you do window.origin equals the string and ull back
and you compare that to the other null origin yes that and ull then you're going to get a hard match
yeah right so so the practical tip here is to basically look for places where that is the security
constraint if it's if it's checking uh like if it's saying event.origin equals event.source then
you know you've probably got a bug because you can set on both the null exactly yeah yeah yeah so uh
essentially i i double checked it i i was like confused for a second because i was like window.source
wait which one was it but it's it is you know event.origin essentially is what needs to be used
to get the null piece out of the the null iframe sending a post message and then you compare that
to window window.origin yep so it's event origin and window origin that if they're doing that
comparison check you're able to uh bypass it by having them both set to null because it does a string
comparison of that value exactly now here's the interesting thing typically if the origin was null on
that page then you know there's not a lot of other stuff you can do you can't iframe hop or anything
like that um but you can do requests uh still fetch requests still work and like so you can do a bunch
of uh stuff with it if you're able to like pop an xss inside of it or something like that um and this
so um yeah so i guess that's where do i go down some other post message stuff or do i go into the
iframe stuff now tricky tricky tricky yeah just whichever one's the most relevant to what we're
talking about yeah i i guess i'll stay in post message and then we'll go back to it really quick
okay a couple couple other quick shout outs is that post messages a lot of people don't know that post
messages the first parameter in you know dot post message is your message and that can be uh an
object not just a string a lot of people think it's a string and then they run like json dot parse on
it or whatever right that can be an actual object okay so you can just pass in curly brackets you know
whatever um inside javascript and it will work just fine um uh what's also interesting there is that you
can send complex types through uh post message some of them um for example big int is it is a javascript
object or like type that is not like you know json's stringifiable uh and you can send that through
post message interesting so um so if there's ever something on the other side that's expecting only
json stringifiable things you're probably going to go down a weird code path that's not unexpected
yeah and it can also send some regex related stuff it can send like there's a ton of stuff that that
you can do with that yeah if if it is um not doing like strict type checking um so keep in mind that
you're not just constrained to the basic json types right string array object you know integer that
sort of thing you can send more complex types through post message as well cool yeah that's awesome okay
last one on last one on post messages is this concept called message ports okay so you said you
wanted a little analogy i'll give you an analogy for this one i tried with the other one you know it's
like a letter you're throwing it back and forth between the different frames right um but message
ports are very much like one of those little cans you know with a string on the other end yeah right and you
kind of put the can up to your ear and you can listen and you can like throw somebody else the other side
of it and then you know talk into it and then they can listen um that's kind of like what these message
ports are okay so essentially instead of post messaging into a window you post message into a uh a
message port okay and only the person that has a reference to the message port on the other side will be able to listen
to that message um so you're you see this sometimes nowadays um so that people don't lose references to
windows and like try to figure all that out they just shoot a port the person that the you know the
other side has the port and then we just communicate over this port now um and depending on which tool
you're using to like monitor message ports um you know or your post messages it may or may not hook these
messages ports so understand that there could be some some post message communication happening in the
background that you know fancy tracker for firefox or fronds is old post message tracker they may not
be hooking into okay yeah so these are not your traditional style ports this is like another place
where we're overloading like the word message is overloaded and the word port is overloaded here
yeah yeah so it's a little different so these are not ports like on like a web server and these are yeah
yeah these these are just these are just like essentially it's an object you throw data into it
you know and and uh and the data comes out the other side regardless of what frame has the the reference
um so yeah i could see your face fitting a little bit well what i'm curious about is like does does this um
is this uh resilient to like closing the other tab and reopening like is it stored like some sort of
like local storage where it's like it knows that that page can like reopen the same port it had
opened before the same message port like i'm just curious like what value it adds i don't know i don't
know how i don't know how you would store it i i think i i think that it is not resilient of that okay
you know but but it is still a browser feature it's not like a web page feature yeah it is and it's
facilitated via via the browser and you know um you know you're throwing these messages into instead of
a window you're throwing them into a port okay and then it's coming out the other side right it's
kind of the thought behind it yeah besides that is it treated very similar to post message like does
it still have a dot event or like an event um yeah okay yeah it does and um and i will also say if you
in the past i have been using some weird tooling for these and like not been able to catch message
ports and i think even fancy tracker for chrome which uh is really good i think it sometimes it has
some problems with message ports recently i i've seen so um whenever i i suspect there's some
communication happening in the background i just find the event listener and set a conditional breakpoint
inside of it uh that just does console.log and just logs to the console okay um as sort of like a
redundant hook to make sure i'm monitoring all communication that comes through those those um
those message ports yeah that's a sick tip right i mean people like we're immediately going to ask okay
if it's if if the things i'm using to listen to post messages aren't finding this how do i do it right
and so yeah good tip yeah all right so that's what i had for post messages um let's go and jump over to
iframe tricks since we were talking about that just a second ago so um the first thing that's really
interesting about iframes is you know knowing how to create this node origin which is essentially
specifying the sandbox attribute um inside of that sandbox attribute you can specify a bunch of different
um like permissions that uh the sandbox attribute or the sandbox iframe has okay a couple of these are
allow same origin allow scripts you know allow pop-ups those sort of things right um and understanding
what each one of those does is really important to be able to craft um really good payloads um using these
okay i have a really i have a really kind of like dumb but maybe smart question here i think when it comes
to talk about iframes especially around front end hacking it's it's like um always a little bit
unclear in my mind like who like if you're working in an iframe or if you're the one creating the iframe
to then do the hacking right because like obviously a normal website can have an iframe but then also
like a normal website that you're hacking can be iframed by you on your domain which i assume is often
where you're hacking but then i know sometimes if you have like html injection then you're like on one of
their domains putting in your putting in an iframe to one of their other domains to pop a bug right
and so i think that some i think that sometimes is like a little confusing to my brain to wrap around
it so in this case the majority of attacks come from you taking your domain and you just putting in
code that creates or instantiates an iframe to the vulnerable domain right and that's almost what you're
always doing or or are you then also using that to then do post messages to it to the uh to the other
window it's it's all of the above you just described the the beauty of iframes and like
freaking client side yeah loveliness dude um is that yeah all of those right there could there
could be an iframe on their page there could be an iframe on your page you could be iframeing your
own page iframeing your own page to create a null origin which is a separate origin from your attacker page
and then use that null origin to open up another page you know like there there's just like a ton of
fun okay aren't you just aren't you just thrilled you're not looking as thrilled no no no no i'm just
thinking i'm just thinking through like if there's like an easy way to conceptualize this is it kind of
like um is it kind of like post messages basically have and not just post messages but i guess other iframe
tricks as well but is it basically like you have a a set of tools in your toolbox which are both the
ways in which um like the different parameters with which a message can be sent which are like kind of
the things that you mentioned above right like whether it is yeah a null origin or not or and like
the domain that you're on and then also depending on the cookies that exist for that domain and then
those um those sets of attributes control both what you can do and what might be vulnerable and so you
have to like basically test all of those different things this is good this is elevating my thinking a
little bit here from my nuts and bolts okay so let me try to abstract it a little bit yeah for you um
uh having you know an iframe is for several purposes one is a window reference right so i need to be
able to reference a a victim's you know window of that origin right so that's useful for scenarios
where you're like sending post messages or or something like that right um so getting a window
reference an iframe is one way to do that another way to do that is window.open which just opens up a
new tab by getting a window reference you mean like the victim would go to your website
then you would you would load an iframe to the website that has a vulnerability on it and and then
you can reference that window now and you can now attack the victim exactly but before that you didn't
have a window to even reference you need a place to stand right you know like you know what's that
that quote from like some philosopher like give me a lever and a place to stand and i can move the earth
archimedes lever yeah yeah that's it and and and so you know that's kind of how i think about this a lot of
what i think about this a lot of time is i need a place to stand when i'm when i am you know using
these window references um so that's one one way the other the other piece is oftentimes or sometimes
you can incur constraints on those domains uh when they are in an iframe or um yeah you can control the
context in which they load that maybe that's a little bit better right um and you see this with
credentialless iframes you see this with um sandboxed iframes right um these are ways that you can
control the context in which interesting okay this is making sense to me now because you control
the parameters of the iframe being loaded if you load it with different settings if you want to
think about it that way then that actually can change what occurs inside of that iframe exactly yeah
so so a really good example of this is um one that i mentioned just a second ago let's say you
you create a attacker controlled page and that attacker controlled page has a null origin attacker
controlled iframe right so i'm iframing myself yep i've got it set to null origin and then i from there
i i have in the sandbox i have allow pop-ups and allow scripts right so i can run javascript and i
can uh allow pop-ups for this sandbox iframe yeah so from that sandbox iframe i do a window.open to
you know with the victim's site or whatever now that victim's site has the null origin as well right
um it it inherits this is one thing that i really want to emphasize here it inherits the sand boxed
properties of the attacker control null origin page yep okay so if you if you said um let's say you said
no no script right let's say you said no script and you did the pop-up via a uh an a tag or something
like that right in straight html right that victim page is now running without any job script
that's so weird so that's so if they ended up on router.com and you did this all of a sudden a new
window would pop up to the to the victim website google.com to google.com with no javascript with
no javascript javascript is not allowed to run okay you know and and and that's one of the beautiful
things about this is like you are incurring constraints yeah unanticipated constraints on
these third-party sites yes right um and another example and i'll give a shout out to um uh to jordan
in the the uh cool research channel on the critical thinking discord he's just constantly dropping cool
shit in there man um hopefully by the time this episode goes live he'll have his write-up um on
lab.ctv.show up on this sort of thing but um one of the things he dropped in the chat recently was that
he was able to use this and he the things he specified were allow same origin allow pop-ups allow scripts but
he did not specify allow forms so what was happening is there was a page that was auto submitting a form
right and he needed it to not auto submit a form so that he could he could attack it right uh and so
he used this constraint it inherited the sandboxed properties of the other origin yeah right of the
other and it doesn't necessarily have to be a null origin right in this scenario he he said allow same
origin so it was just the normal origin for this page yeah but it did inherit the fact that it's not
allowed to submit forms so when it went to auto submit the form it failed it failed right and so
there are lots of ways that you can sort of manipulate these target pages that have been
spawned from sandboxed iframes does that make sense yep yeah and you know a lot of these again are
affecting different code paths like they may have expected that to always auto submit and so when it
didn't what happens some sort of fallback right you know like it's man sometimes you see the craziest
fallbacks like uh i think i've seen one of the fallbacks i've seen for like not being able to parse json
was just run eval on the string oh my gosh and it's like what um fallback execute rc yeah exactly it's
like okay uh yeah so a lot of these fallbacks can trigger unanticipated code paths um so knowing about
these uh sandboxed uh like attributes that you can apply to these third-party sites can be really valuable
yeah um i will say there is an exception to that so i i said i talked about sandbox inheritance here
um the exception to that is allow top navigation so there is this specific um flag that you typically
need to specify in your sandboxed uh iframe yep that's that will allow it to navigate the top level
page there is a specific exception made in the docs for inherited window you know windows that have
inherited those sandboxed properties from a iframe uh but it was opened via window.open so it's in its
new tab right because it's saying okay well hold on a sec like we can't not let them navigate themselves
right right and because it's in a new window so that is going to have implicitly have allowed top
navigation associated with it cool and it will be able to navigate itself what does allow top nav do
allow top navigation allows you to navigate the url bar for that tab okay yeah so i just wanted to
make sure i put that that um caveat out there are you tracking with me so far i know that that's very
convoluted i'm tracking extremely well with you and that's that's great because i you know came in
not knowing you know nearly as much and so i think even our beginner listeners will have followed almost
all this so that's great i i think um i think a lot of times like i mean i love this stuff obviously but i
i you know whenever i go to talk about it it's so nuanced and convoluted i'm sure i'm i'm sure freaking
demo or like some some turbo or whatever jorian some of the listeners are going to be like find
something that i said in this episode i'm sure in the corrections channel so please do because that's
how i learn as well but um this is uh is my best my best shot at representing these concepts you're
doing great all right so uh let's talk about two more things uh credential lists is one of them which
is another attribute on iframes and this one was it's fairly new actually uh but the thing you need
to know about this we've covered it on the pod before is that if you apply the credential list
attribute to an iframe yeah it just means that it is using a new ephemeral
context so no cookies no local storage no no nothing associated with that domain is going to survive
that credential list context cool um and and so that's useful if you've got you know a cookie that
you need not to be set for your attack to happen but of course that cookie is going to be set if the
if the user even uses this website right right so you need to like get them in a state where
they don't have the cookie set but they're still logged into the page or something like that right
um credential list uh is really good for this um and here's something that i should have looked up before
the pod actually maybe we'll pause and i'll look it up right now i'm not sure that credential lists
inherits on window.open so let me go check that right now okay it doesn't look like it inherits the
credential lists uh attribute so this one's only uh helpful if you're like inside of an iframe itself which
does make this a little tricky because not every page nowadays is is iframeable due to like extreme
options and csp so yeah so that's uh interesting little nuance but it has saved our butts a couple
times um you got that one i know we've covered that one before yeah no that's great i was gonna ask are
there any other iframe attributes that you think are key that we haven't mentioned yet or that you
think are interesting or we've mentioned most of them um yeah i mean these are the ones that's just kind of
popped into head um there there are a couple things the name attribute is really important right that
that controls the name of the frame yeah um and we'll talk about that one in just a second with
window hijacking um there are lots of interesting other attributes like you can specify a csp that
uh the victim page must conform to and if it doesn't load that csp then it's not gonna load you know
so there's there are some interesting things you can do with that um but we'll we'll save those for a
time when i've uh researched them a little bit more recently and can talk about them more uh more
clearly um the one i did want to specify though was window hijacking which goes back to the name
attribute that i was mentioning before so um here's a really cool thing um you can name your windows and
your frames and stuff like that various things so uh let's say you name your win uh your window abc or
whatever right if uh there there is a scenario where you can force a victim page to open their window.open
into that iframe so so consider this scenario okay and actually if you want to visualize it joseph so you
can see click that um frame hijacking attacker page uh link that i put in the in the um doc there yeah
consider this scenario you've got an attacker controlled page um you embed inside of that
page an iframe to the victim site called abc sure okay so that's the name then you do a window.open to
a victim page that victim page uh you know goes through some a lot flow whatever and then does a
window.open with the name abc right of course it wouldn't be abc it'd be like a login session or
whatever right what will happen is it will look for any other pages before in the browsing context
yes that are the same origin as itself so it has to be the same as victim.com sure and then it will
open into that iframe rather than doing a window pop-up right and since you embedded that iframe in the
first place right you control where it's pointing to so then you can you know redirect it to something else
and then or like put something in the hash or something like that and then when it redirects
back to the victim page and that thing is still in the hash it might try to read the hash and do
something with it right um so this is what i'm talking about like having iframes open allow you
to control the context in which pages are running and in this scenario we just hijacked a pop-up right
and instead we put it in our attacker controlled page that's super we have control over it that's super
weird and cool that that works isn't that amazing yeah i do think that another disjoint in my
understanding is from like what is possible inside of an iframe that is iframe from it like attacker.com
right sure like yeah that's interesting you can't redirect it for sure like that that is what you said
you can't just like reach in and then get those cookies right yeah you can't right yeah because
there's yeah there's still and you can't even you can't even see them on the way in even though you
i-framed it right right right yeah so it's interesting it is a little weird like knowing the
nuances about what's possible with that iframe is another reason why i think there's like a gap in
understanding between people who are like really in the front end versus those that aren't
yeah yeah and and the only way to get that is experimentation yeah is for you to listen to this
podcast and like pop open your browser and like build pages that represent the scenarios we're
talking about and toy around with it yourself yeah um or you can do what you do which is understand it
at like just a deep enough level where you can say hey this is weird hey justin yes this is your
shit and this is what i do for you with ai stuff you know and uh and then we kind of bounce off of
each other which is great no i think this is huge though and honestly i think all of this front-end stuff
is extremely uh important and good even for kind of this like new ai hacking stuff because there's so
much html injection and so much like room for xss and other front-end like um sensory when it comes to
all of these different ai apps that are popping up because they very often are either i-framing it in
or doing translation between markdown to html or they just straight up have xss to begin with so
no i think this is like all extremely um beneficial so so so here's another really interesting thing
okay oftentimes what will happen is let's say you're on like some ai page right and it's generating
a markdown output which has a link in it yep um if that link is allowed if that a tag is allowed to
have the target attribute then you've got something really cool here okay uh because what you can do is
let's say let's say we're on gemini for example okay gemini uh has an invisible iframe you know in
it to do like analytics or like you know supply whatever feedback form or something like that right
that that feedback form or whatever is named you know abc what if you can get the ai to spit out a
a tag that has target equal to abc when they click that link it's going to open into that iframe wow so
now you've got like a persistent invisible iframe with your attacker controlled page inside of gemini
right and unless that iframe is sandboxed you can also do like you you can uh do like top dot location
navigate and and change the top level page right and there's just or you can send post messages from
like an advantaged position and bypass coop like i'm gonna go i'm gonna go find you this a place
where we can control target and libraries i'm gonna go please please let me know because like um the
target unfortunately the target attribute is a little bit tricky to smuggle in there but if you can
there's like a ton of really cool stuff you can do with it yeah so keep that in mind um all right dude we
man i your boy can yap about client-side stuff hey this is great okay um let me see where we want to go
next let's talk about url parsing okay um this one is kind of an yeah i want to make sure we hit cspt
before we uh sign off too okay we can skip that one we'll hit cspt as well um let's jump to url parsing
first sure uh start us off with a basic one oftentimes backslash slash gets converted into
uh double back or double slash yep which uh will allow you to actually produce an absolute url rather
than a relative url that causes so many bugs so uh like always keep that in mind yeah yeah that's also
probably applicable to ai because like yeah the like i just had the best bug of a amazon ipc and it was
that's a bypass where the um markdown image rendering happened with slash slash so if they
then go fix that with slash slash then backslash forward slash would potentially work to bypass it
right exactly yeah and and you can do you know if it's inside of an attribute or whatever you can do
all sorts of you know encodings html encodings that sort of thing so there's lots of lots of depth that
that can happen there um this is one that is is also quite interesting is that recently and i think we
covered this on the pod as sort of like a side note when it first came out but recently uh chrome
conformed to safari's behavior about parsing javascript uris such that javascript uris can now have a
a host name associated with them so so if you do javascript colon slash slash rhinerrader.com
slash rhinerrader.com is the host name for that javascript uri which doesn't make a lick of
sense that's really weird because like that's not what the uri is for yeah right and they had it
the safer way before which is that it was null yeah but then they were like ah well you know
the spec says that it should be like this and safari's doing it this way so we're also going to do it
this way and the hackers were like yes um so have you seen this use already oh yeah yeah yeah i've
used it many times and i've seen many people use it um but this now makes it so that if there is a
new url right you know parsing of this this um scheme and it does dot hostname and compares it to
like the hostname of this page or something like that then you can have that but then when they do
location dot uh you know window dot location equals this it will run javascript and you can just do
like percent away at the end of the javascript to create a new line because slash slash is a comment
in javascript right yeah so do you see how that works right like javascript colon slash slash now we're
in a comment there's a comment yep then you get the next line who cares what happens there right
it's like just the stars aligning in so many good ways isn't that awesome that's cool yeah um so that
one's a really good one it's very seldom you see new features unlock a bunch of bugs
yeah yeah which i mean i guess people probably reported it as like firefox only bugs already right
but yeah and i've reported it as a safari only bug but last time i reported it uh you know before they
they changed it i saw in the you know in the critical thinkers channel we've got like the data
feeds or whatever and i saw uh on the intent to ship feed that uh they were gonna change it and i
put that in my report and they paid me the full thing like it wasn't gonna because they like chrome
is gonna ship this so it's you know we're just getting ahead of the curve and i was like yes that's
awesome um so that one's a cool one the other one that's really interesting and sort of relates
back to post messages as well is that you know then then the string no that represents the null origin
uh is kind of weird because it is just a string and uh the that string like can be perceived in
different ways so here's an example of how this might work one of the before they i think the
prevalence of uh the url parsing um framework that they have in in in javascript now uh one of the
ways that you would commonly see to parse a uh a url is to create do document.create an a tag and then
set the href to a specific url right um and so let's say you got a post message and you wanted to
extract the host name from that post message in a in a reliable way logic that i've seen before is say
document.create element a a dot href equals event dot origin right so you're setting the href of that a
tag to the origin of the post message and then grab the host name of the a tag which is pre-populated
into that like object yeah um what's interesting is that if you send this from a null origin it passes
null into the href of the a tag and null if you just put null as a string it says oh that's a that's a
relative url that's slash null right and so what is the host name of a relative url oh that's the current
page that we're on right and so it just fills in the very helpfully fills in the current the current
pages host again by the stars aligning only exactly right and and and then it compares it to itself and it's
like always passes right that's cool um so i've seen that logic a couple times when they use um create
element a as like their their way to extract the host name this does not work in new url unfortunately
like uh uh because of some constraints that they have in the system for that uh but it does work
in other methods of extracting the host name yeah um okay you said you wanted to go to cspts next yeah um
dude like the thing is i've talked about cspts so much on this podcast so i don't know i could go a
little bit deeper than what i've got in the in the doc there but um yeah i guess i'll go a little bit
deeper okay so um this is advanced techniques all right all right cspts i'm not going to explain what
cspts are you know tldr you get data from the url or from the path you stick it into a sub resource
request and you can induce path traversal there's also another subset of these i will say that i don't
really know what to call them i kind of think maybe it's like request hijacking but this is when
you take something from a query parameter or a path and you inject it directly into the domain
of a fetch request right so it's not a pass traversal you're just overwriting what host
the the fetch request the sub resource request is is actually going to right so be on the lookout
and this is common in like cloud providers and stuff right yeah totally yeah you you know what i'm
talking about actually um yeah but these sort of um these sort of vulnerabilities are are pretty common and
uh i would say one thing that that is really uh useful to exploit these is knowing that you can
exploit the difference between what what the browser perceives and what actually hits the fetch sync
uh and this was a great shout out by turbo i think he mentioned it on his episode or maybe it was in
the the chat but anything like percent zero nine or like new lines and stuff like that all of that just
get straight stripped from anything passed passed into fetch as a part of the hosting so you can do
you know rhino raider tab dot com and and it will just pull the tab out when it does the fetch
so if there's any sort of like parsing or like um an analysis of that data that you're passing in
you can really you can oftentimes finagle it by adding white space throughout there yeah um and
then and then also just be on the lookout for different levels of encoding here like i think
that's where a lot of the vulnerabilities occur you're not always just going to be able to
insert like a slash or you know a backslash or something you got to try percent 2f percent 5c percent
25 2f percent 25 2c percent 4 4 0 right for the at sign you know like all sorts of things like this that
can sort of break these various contexts yep um okay um going from there let's talk a little bit about
client-side routes um client-side routes i don't know man like i feel like i don't really know how to hack
applications that don't have client-side routes anymore man like it's just so overpowered that in
single page applications that you just have access to essentially like the full app in the js files
like right in front of you yeah i've been doing um hacking on hacker one challenges that don't have
that and they're it's so frustrating i mean it's also really rewarding when you find a new path
especially if it's one that like you're not supposed to have access to and the page actually loads
it's like a massive adrenaline rush but it is weird to go back to those because so many pages are just
single page apps these days yeah i think we talked about it on the pod like last week or the week
before but like you know there's just a totally different approach you've got to take where you're
just like you know looking for patterns brute forcing stuff it is a lot more brute force heavy
whereas with spas um all you have to do is just figure out how these routes are defined and and i i think
the best way to do this in so many levels is just reverse engineer what you've got right what page am
i on okay well that page has got a route somewhere so just take the page put it into con you know
control shift f in dev tools where you're searching all of the js files and then find where the place
where the routes are defined and then just look at every single route right that's like one of the
first things to do on my checklist uh is just like you know go through every single route understand
everything that's happening and go from there um yeah yeah yeah i like that second tip that you have
here that's basically you do it seems like you almost do the same thing for parameters like what what
what and how are all these parameters used how are they parsed what do they do yeah totally and and
and you know look for the nuances in the route definitions as well uh you know because sometimes
there'll be like parameter like uh colon you know path id or you know object id or whatever in there so
they're taking path parameters right um and then also like you said look at the way they're the
framework they're using they're probably going to do consistent parsing or access to given uh query
parameters so are they using url search params are they using like you know a react or a view um
uh piece here to grab grab query parameters and that sort of thing and then look at every single
query parameter that ever gets parsed ever in the whole app right and and understand every single
piece of data that you can pass into this application by a by a force by by forcing them into a specific url
okay so i've obviously heard you talk a lot about client side paths versions and i've seen them a lot of
places but it's just dawning on me that i think that i've failed to test for a ton of places because i
definitely see like the slash colon id or whatever but if that's ever controlled by me i can always
check for if i name that object or if it's like attacker controlled if i have like for example let's
just say it's a username like if it's like slash slash user slash reso if i go make my username dot dot
slash what happens right like yeah yeah there's there's scenarios where you can get stored cspt with that
where it will load you know from the database your name and then that gets causes a path traversal
right what is going on yeah um yeah and then yeah you can also just do you know it's a little bit
trickier when it's path parameters because you got to do like various levels of encoding and stuff like
that but let's say you've got slash user slash you know user id yeah you know do slash user slash percent
to f you know dot dot percent to f you know yeah and you know have that encoded version and if that
if it's resolving those then do percent 25 to f right so you can still find path traversals inside of
path parameters um so definitely be on the lookout for that uh the other thing is that one of the
ways that you know with with the on-site of same-site cookies which you know i think is i feel like
that's a little bit more of an inter intermediate topic but um uh with it with the onset of same-site
cookies um sea surfs are getting a little bit more challenging and one of the ways that you can
exploit sea surfs um pretty reliably nowadays is just by making sure that the request originates
from the attack the victim's page um and a lot of times that happens via these callback routes
where it hits a third-party provider whatever i want to link my account and then it comes back to
this page on a specific route that is responsible for completing that linkage right but if you can just
grab your attacker control data redirect the victim to that finalize route right then it will send a uh you
know a post request or whatever to modify the victim's account then boom you got a sort of a c-surf oh
that's cool that's really cool yeah um and then sometimes you can hijack those as well right maybe
there's a cspt inside of that and it's sending a post request so you use it to hit a different endpoint
and then do a different c-surf right um so it's this whole cspt to c-surf idea that was really covered
well by um doyan sec in their in their cspt uh paper they did a while back um so lots of lots of
neat nuances there um dude your throat going out my throat is getting a little raspy i'm going to close
it up with um just uh one two more little quick shouts and that is one i kind of mentioned url search
params earlier but that is a uh a class in javascript that is used to parse create like query parameters
right so really good place for dom dom logger plus plus um hooks and also uh just control effing for url
search params to see where parameters are being parsed yeah um so that's just a little tip i'll
throw out there and also do not ignore on hash change events because hash change is something that
you can control as a as a hacker right on your evil page i don't know if this is something that's commonly
i didn't know that yeah so how does this happen yeah so let's say you do a window.open to a victim
page right and you know what url they're on you can do that same window.open again to that same url
with a different hash and it will swap the hash without refreshing oh interesting and it will
trigger the on hash change event on that page and sometimes when the hash changes various things will
occur on that page um so that's really cool yeah is on hash change how like um it like jumps to
um different like table contents buttons or no uh sometimes depending on yeah or is that there is some
page load uh there is some functionality for that but i i think like most of the stuff now that i'm
talking about here is just hooked into this event that you can register it says hey whenever the hash
changes i want this code to run and you look at that code and you say oh okay well one of those is a
redirect so i redirect to this hash and then it you know drops your javascript source or something like
that you know your javascript uri into a window location or something yeah um so great stuff there
um the last thing that i had here this is and this is just like a random piece that i decided to throw
into this episode i probably should have bumped this up to the top uh when covered it during news but
it's actually a post from tear jank back from 2021 wow that somehow recently came across my my uh x feed
um and he was saying that something that really blew my mind which is and this is something i guess to
cover a little bit more from a higher level perspective is like there's this concept of the
dom right which is the rendered um uh the document object model that it's like your html that's been
shown on the page and a lot of times for stuff to run you have to create an element in js and then
attach it into the page right you could do document.body.appendchild or something like that
so you create the element now it's just living in javascript land and then you insert it into the
dom makes sense what's really weird here is that uh what terjank tweeted out was that like you can
create an an element so let's say you do document.create element div or whatever and then you say div dot
inner html equals you know image source equals x on error equals alert one right that still has not been
inserted into the dom yet so it's not like it shouldn't be rendering uh but for some reason that will run
uh that on event on error handler will run uh are there any protections like obviously dom purify
uh implies that it's purifying the dom yeah would that like not get purified because it's not
uh that's kind of the first thing that came to my mind as well was like i feel like some of these
parsers are probably like depending on the fact that they can like take the html and stick it inside
of like another html element that they crafted in the javascript you know vm or whatever and then like
do stuff to it right but but if you even get it to that point you're already done because it's gonna run
it makes me think it makes me think that there are a lot of cases where people have like tried to get
xss but failed but they never try to dot enter html yeah yeah well it it's very it's very interesting
and there could be other nuances around dot enter html because i know that that's you know that is a
pretty dangerous function that a lot of um uh people will try to uh avoid when they're doing these
parsing but i i still wouldn't have thought it would have triggered i i wouldn't have thought that it
would trigger even without being inserted into the dom and and it is interesting as well because i know
this is just making me think a little bit i know that there is a bug in dom purify where if you put a
meta tag in into the dom purified like uh parser that meta tag will be applied to the page uh even though
it got sanitized away so so they are like definitely taking that in doing something with it where so i
don't i don't think this is a dom purify bypass because that's like a very vanilla paper that i'm
saying here but like but like um there's definitely some weird nuance of uh of that because that's the
same thing that's happening with this meta tag that uh jrock mentioned back on his episode back in the day
so something on something odds happening there i got to double click into that a little bit i'm sure
something is will come out of this episode almost definitely yeah for sure man um all right that was
a lot of justin yapping you got any questions about any of that or do we think we're uh we're good for
now no dude i think you explained it super well i uh it's funny this is like the advanced episode but
we also were like super beginner all the way to the advanced stuff so i think this will be super useful
for both sets of listeners which is probably great because if it was only advanced then i feel like half
people stop listening immediately but there will be enough listeners like me that will like hang on for
the ride because you uh you bridged it so well so thank you for that of course man yeah i think there's
a lot of a lot of both here a lot of you know covering some of the foundational concepts but also like
this super weird like double null origin iframe stuff that's that's pretty whack so hopefully we
triggered some some advanced minds out there to go down some some paths with some of this stuff and help
some of the beginners along as well yeah dude sweet all right man peace good episode
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show/discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there